do you find it compelling or
useful to think about human civilization
from the perspective of the ideas versus
the perspective
of the individual human brains so almost
thinking about the ideas or the memes
this is the dawkins thing as the
organisms
and then the humans as just like uh
vehicles for briefly carrying those
organisms as they jump around and spread
yeah for propagating them mutating them
putting selective pressure on them etc
yeah um i mean i found um dawkins
interpret or his his launching of the
idea of memes is just kind of an
afterthought to his unbelievably
brilliant book about the selfish gene
like
what a ps to put at the end of a long
chunk of writing
profoundly interesting i view the
relationship though between human and
humans and memes is probably an
oversimplification
but maybe a little bit like the
relationship between flowers and bees
right do flowers have bees or do bees in
a sense
have flowers and the answer is
it is a very very symbiotic relationship
in which both have
semi-independent roles that they play
and both
are highly dependent upon the other and
so
in the case of bees obviously you know
you could see the flowers being this
monolithic structure
physically in relation to any given bee
and it's the source of
food and sustenance so you could kind of
say well flowers have bees
but on the other hand the flowers would
obviously be doomed
they weren't being pollinated by the
bees so you could kind of say well you
know
bees you know flowers are really
expression of what the bees need
and the truth is a symbiosis so with
with memes and human minds
our brains are are clearly the petri
dishes
in which memes are either propagated or
not propagated get mutated or don't get
mutated if they are
the venue in which competition selective
competition
plays out between different memes so all
of that is very true and you could look
at that and say
really the human mind is a production of
memes
and ideas have us rather than us having
ideas
but at the same time let's take a catchy
tune
as an example of a meme um that catchy
tune
did originate in a human mind somebody
had to structure that thing
and as much as i like elizabeth
gilbert's ted talk about how
the universe i'm simplifying but you
know kind of
the ideas find their way and it's
beautiful ted talk it's very lyrical she
talked about
you know ideas and prose kind of beaming
into our minds
and you know she talked about needing to
pull over the side of the road when she
got inspiration
for a particular paragraph or a
particular idea and a burning need to
write that down
i love that i find that beautiful as a
as a writer as a novelist
myself i've never had that experience
and
i think that really most things that do
become
memes are the product of a great deal of
deliberate
and willful exertion of a conscious mind
and so like the bees
and the flowers i think there's a great
symbiosis and they
both kind of have one another ideas have
us but we have ideas for real
you